so deerra is I think maybe in her 50s
60s female in Bay Area who has suffered
from bipolar
disorder much of her
life and you know pretty
successfully treated for the Mania side
of things over the years had a
psychiatrist taking care of that part in
Moren and happened to slip into this
pretty severe depressive episode a
couple of years back this has
been maybe like four or five years now
her psychiatrist had actually gone to
see a talk that I gave at this mood
disorders day like the year before we
were talking this really early on when
we were working on a rapid acting neuros
stimulation approach so the psychiatrist
had heard the talk and then her patient
kind of fell into this really bad
suicidal depression and so she reached
out to me to treat her and I got on the
phone I'll never forget it was like a
Wednesday and I I got on the phone with
her psychiatrist and she was telling me
like symptomatic ially how bad off she
was and I was like I don't think we can
treat her outpatient she's like way too
ill I think she needs to go to the
impatient hospital and essentially gave
her some information on how to do that I
see her the next morning and and she's
in really bad shape what does that mean
like how did that show up when people
are at the level where they like kind of
definitively need to go into the
hospital they're not really totally
communicative anymore and they've got
some cognitive issues sometimes and so
in in her case you know she couldn't
look you in the eyes you look at the
ground and she was doing this rocking
thing mhm which you can see in pretty
severe depression Catatonia overlap
symptoms you know I mean she's like at
the kind of the very end of the spectrum
one of the highest severity patients
we've ever treated a score of 50 on the
modus of 60 like very very severe right
and just rocking and not really talking
and and husbands were counting
everything and she had bipolar one so
she was hypomanic I think or manic like
two weeks before and then dropped into
this very very severe depression so it
was her daughter and the husband they're
sitting in the room with me and I said
they want me to treat her and I say
listen like it's Friday we go Monday to
Friday you have to find a way basically
to keep her well from now until Monday
and that means and by well you mean safe
like preventing self yeah yeah exactly
keep her not having a suicide attempt
basically from now until Monday she's
very suicidal and you know and I said
you're going to have to like take every
knife gun
chemical like scissors everything out of
the house the whole all of it has to go
and you guys have to be on like a
24-hour like you know watch until Monday
Monday morning rolls around we bring her
in and the craziest thing we had like
repair on the motor threshold coil which
is the coil you Ed to kind of get
calibrated on the intensity and it
shorted out the device blew the
capacitor Bank up on the on the first
stimulator blew your fleux capacitor
yeah yeah at like 700 a.m. and I mean
you can't imagine how stressful that was
so we had a second machine and I'll tell
you about this later we were running
this like you know trait hypnotizability
modulation study and it was over at the
scanner so pretty far away and this
thing's way like 100 lb so so I had to
send my team over there run over there
and grab it bring it over and luckily we
were able to kind of get her going and
treat her with the second machine and I
mean she was she was in really really
bad shape that morning and by 5:00 that
afternoon she was basically normal and
the next morning she was like totally
zeroed out and completely normal meaning
no suicidality meaning no depression no
nothing I mean she looked like any
person walking the street like totally
normal and that was in 24 hours and
we've seen this with with bipolar
patients quicker right it'll happen
really quick for like a bipolar one
patient you can get it done in sometimes
in a day just for Clarity by get it done
and don't worry people listen we're
going to Define terms and get into all
this but you're talking about
accelerated TMS yeah we're talking about
accelerated TMS so we you know our rapid
acting or stimulation approach we're
able to get people out of these states
and into normal mood in short periods of
time generally like 2.6 days on average
for major depression patients but it's
quicker with bipolar we've seen
especially with bipolar 1 patients so
she was totally out of it in in 24 hours
that was like right around July 4th or
something and so the whole team left I
guess gu we'll talk about maybe talk
about caffeine later too so so my wife
and I are like big Phil's Coffee fans
and so I I'll never forget this either
so we go down to the Phil's Coffee in
Pao Alto after I saw them I'll never
forget it Clark Leman her husband also
went to Phils didn't know I was going to
be there and I I look over and this
guy's just kind of staring at me and I
was like hey how are you good to see you
again I like just saw the guy like 10
minutes ago and he's like I still don't
understand what happened you know and it
and it it makes sense right like to take
somebody from like the worst you've ever
seen them mood-wise to like normal in
such a short period of time was
remarkable for him and after that period
they actually went out and really were
helpful with a lot of the philanthropy
that led to all the trials being funded
and ultimately you know the clearance
and and Clark and derra really were
Advocates and have continued to be
advocates for for this to kind of get it
out into the world it was totally based
off of of that experience of him feeling
helpless you know and going from that to
to feeling like it was all solved and I
think she went maybe a year completely
asymptomatic and ended up needing to
retreated again at some point but gets
like these little touch-ups here and
there and is able to stay well ongoing
and depression you know as they tell me
depression is not her problem anymore
she's a great kind of illustrative case
of what this can do and I I think what
the what the promise of it can
be